[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt
heute gibt's wir versprochen noch mal
ein leckeres Pralinenrezept und nicht
nur eins sondern direkt zwei zwei Sorten
Pralinen heute mal ganz ohne Hohlkörper
ihr wisst normalerweise oder in den
meisten Rezepten habe ich jetzt bisher
immer Schokoladenhohlkörper verwendet
was auch echt sehr gut ist denn dann ist
die Pralinenherstellung wirklich einfach
aber ich möchte dich auch eine
Alternative bieten an was sie in diesem
Rezept aber auch machen könnt diese
Füllung und ich gleich herstellen werde
die könnt ihr theoretisch auch in
Hohlkörper füllen könnt ihr auch machen
aber heute zeigen euch einfach mal ne
andere Möglichkeit zum einen werde ich
jetzt Erdnuss Pralinen herstellen mit
einer Gold Schokolade Karamell
Schokolade und dann noch Haselnuss
Pralinen und die werden dann auch
richtig lecker also beide Sorten
wirklich sehr gut ich konnte mich nicht
entscheiden also gibt's heute gleich
beides jetzt werde ich mit der Füllung
anfangen und für die Variante 1 als er
für die Erdnuss Variante da habe ich
hier 160 Gramm Erdnüsse die sind schon
gesalzen
240 Gramm Schokolade dann nehme ich die
gold Schokolade die schmeckt so ein
bisschen karamellig und zum Verfeinern
noch einen halben Teelöffel Zimt das
war's das sind einfach nur diese drei
Zutaten und ihr könnt wenn ihr sagt Zimt
mögt ihr nicht so gerne dann in der
andere Gewürze oder lasst sie weckt denn
die pure Erdnuss schmeckt auch schon
sehr gut könnte hier auch direkt
parallel arbeiten nehme ich die Erdnüsse
erstmal rösten und die Schokolade
schmelzen und weil es jetzt eine Füllung
wird müsst ihr die Schokolade jetzt auch
nicht temperieren sondern eher schmelzt
sie einfach entweder in der Mikrowelle
oder einfach auf dem warmen Wasserbad
und die Erdnüsse rösten bis so dass sie
nicht so dunkel werden aber auch schon
bisschen Farbe bekommen und lecker
duften
wenn eine große Menge machen wollt und
jetzt sagt ihr macht jetzt echt viele
Pralinen und auch verschiedene Sorten
gleichzeitig dann könnte sie auch auf
ein Backblech einfach im Backofen rösten
da rösten sie auch relativ gleichmäßig
und vor allem muss man einfach schneller
fertig aber bei der Menge geht es auch
ganz gut auf dem Herd aber aufpassen
dass er nicht verbrennt
[Musik]
es reicht schon völlig die kurzum damit
sie abfüllen die Pfanne brauche ich
gleich noch mal aber ich wasche sie kurz
ab damit das Salz einfach weg ist von
den Erdnüssen die werden jetzt hier kurz
ja ich lasse dir kurz lauwarm abkühlen
die Schokolade ist auch schon
geschmolzen und diese Karamell
Schokolade die hatte ich den Geschmack
durch ganz natürliche Art und Weise der
Zucker wird nämlich einfach
karamellisiert und kommt dann mit der
weißen oder wird dann zu weißer
Schokolade praktisch verarbeitet und
durch den karamellisierten Zucker ist es
einfach nur Gold Schokoladen Karamell
Schokolade Rezepte einfach und schönen
Karamellgeschmack dann die gesalzene
geröstete Erdnüsse und Zimt und dann ist
es gleich eine richtig leckere Füllung
aber das lasse ich hier kurz abkühlen
die Schokolade ist auch warm genug das
passt dann sage ich euch noch kurz die
zweite Füllung da kann ich da nämlich
auch schon die Nüsse rösten und die
Schokolade schmelzen
für die haselnussfüllung nehme ich auch
160 Gramm Haselnüsse und die sind
bereits geschält gehackt und geröstet
ich werde aber gleich noch mal rösten
dann habe ich auch hier 240 Gramm
Kuvertüre ich nehme sie zart bitter 20
Gramm Puderzucker und dann habe ich
jetzt hier noch zwei passen nämlich eine
Tonka und eine zitronenpaste ja bis
jetzt noch Puderzucker ergänzt weil ich
nicht satt bitterkuvertüre nehmen aber
wir können zum Waschen auch Milch
Schokolade nehmen also Vollmilch
Kuvertüre aber das geht auch die ist
auch schon Süßer ich muss aber sagen ich
mag es ganz gerne wenn wenn mehr Kakao
enthalten ist und weniger Zucker ich mag
es auch gerne dunkel und her aber durch
den Puderzucker wird es auch gar nicht
herab also die wird so von der Füllung
her von der Süße her wirklich perfekt
also keine Sorge da braucht man nicht
noch mehr zu kommen wie gesagt sind die
Haselnüsse schon gerüstet aber ich werde
jetzt noch mal rasten weil mir das noch
nicht intensiv genug ist und ich nehme
es einfach die geschälten denn wenn ihr
jetzt ganze Haselnüsse nehmen könnt ihr
auch machen die können doch in der
Pfanne rösten dann löst sich die Haut
von bis und die könnt ihr später dann
einfach so abreiben und könnt dann die
Haselnüsse einfach zerkleinern
während die dunkle Schokolade noch
schmilzt und die Haselnüsse abkühlen
kann ich jetzt mit der Füllung ein
breiter machen jetzt braucht ihr einen
Mixer der die Nüsse gut zerkleinert
mache ich jetzt da oben wenn übrigens
die Kenwood habt dann könnt ihr da unten
auch die Schokolade schmelzen und ihr
könntet theoretisch auf die Nüsse darin
rösten dies der bis 180 Grad und dann
können wir das einfach rühren lassen und
in der Zeit was anderes machen
[Musik]
braucht auf jeden Fall im starken Mixer
der die Nüsse einfach feinster malt und
dann schon zu einer Paste
Weiterverarbeiter Zynismus deswegen gehe
ich da jetzt direkt mit der Stufe gleich
hoch
[Musik]
und jetzt gebe ich hier noch das
Zimtpulver dazu und die Schokolade und
zerkleinertes noch kurz oder vermisst
einfach schön miteinander und dann ist
die Füllung schon fertig
und die riecht jetzt schon richtig gut
[Musik]
Telefon richtig schöne Konsistenz und
vor allem riecht es sehr gut ich muss
sagen die eignet sich fast schon als
Brotaufstrich und jetzt fühlt er sie
entweder in den Spritzbeutel um oder
einfach in der Dosierflasche die
Dosierflasche sollte aber eine große
Öffnung haben falls doch noch
Nussstückchen drin sind und
dann stelle ich die kurz zur Seite
stellen auf die zweite Füllung her
und dann ist der Papst schon erledigt
oder Josch so direkt auf Crepes drauf
war
alles sauber machen und dann Füllung
haselnussfüllung und
Zitrone
[Musik]
und dann die Schokolade dazu verrühren
und auch Apfel und die würde jetzt in
den Spritzbeutel dann zeige ich einfach
beide Varianten
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier beide Füllungen und
weil wir jetzt heute keine Hohlkörper
verwenden also ihr könnt die jetzt wie
gesagt auch ebenso Schokoladen
Hohlkörper füllen und könnt ganz einfach
Pralinen herstellen aber wenn ihr seid
ihr wollt meine andere Methode sind dann
diese hier dann bräuchtet ihr allerdings
Silikonförmchen so kleine
Pralinenförmchen und könnte hier rein
füllen und dann wird nämlich die Füllung
einfach im Kühlschrank fest und ich kann
sie dann mit der Kuvertüre überziehen
einfach ist es tatsächlich mit
Hohlkörpern zu arbeiten weil er dann
schon diese Schoko Hülle habt aber wie
gesagt so sieht er noch mal beides jetzt
rein füllen und dann in Kühlschrank
stellen bist du schön kalt sind
[Musik]
okay die Förmchen sind jetzt gefüllt und
kommen jetzt in den Kühlschrank damit
die Füllung schön fest wird am besten
vier bis sechs Stunden die übrige
Füllung die kann ich später einfach noch
mal erwärmen und dann in die leeren
Förmchen wieder rein füllen Dennis sagen
ich habe leider nur jeweils eine dieser
Formen oder ich überlege sogar ob ich
den Rest in Hohlkörper füllen mal gucken
jedenfalls kann ich die Füllung aber
auch einfach wieder erwärmt die muss
jetzt schön fest werden damit der Kern
also diese flüssige Masse jetzt ganz
fest wird ja später die Füllung und dann
kann ich sie mit der Kuvertüre
überziehen
und wenn sie dann gut gekühlt sind dann
zieht ihr die Silikonform so ein
bisschen in alle Richtungen um die
Pralinen zu lösen und stürzte dann raus
[Musik]
zi bralin jetzt wieder in den
Kühlschrank zurückgestellt damit die
Füllung einfach nicht weich wird jetzt
kann ich die Kuvertüre vorbereiten für
die helle Sorte nehme ich natürlich
wieder die Karamell Kuvertüre
und ihr braucht da jetzt schon eine
große Menge also schon so 450 bis 500 g
damit ich auch ordentlich spiel habe zum
Eintauchen ich werde später nicht die
komplette Kuvertüre benutzen aber die
Kuvertüre lässt sich ja wunderbar
aufbewahren und ein from nächsten Mal
kann man sehr wieder weiter verwerten
also ist hier entweder in der Mikrowelle
oder über dem Wasserbad schmelzen am
besten so ungefähr zwei Drittel mit der
impfmethode und jetzt drauf achten dass
das Wasser nicht mehr kocht und auch
kein Wasser in die Kuvertüre gelangt und
das mache ich jetzt einmal covid Wasser
gelangt und jetzt mache ich das einfach
mit der Karamell covid höre mit der
Goldkarte und einmal mit der zart bitter
für die dunkle Variante
einrühren und ich Kuvertüre bewegen
damit sie gleichmäßig schnell
und wenn die Kuvertüre geschmolzen ist
dann vom Wasserbad runternehmen und
den Rest Rhein Rhön zum runterkühlen
auf der Verpackung von der Callebaut
Kuvertüre steht auch immer diese
Temperatur Kurve da kann man immer ein
bisschen nachschauen aber im Prinzip
einfach über dem Wasserbad erwärmen
lange genug damit auch Ihnen die
Schokolade oder die Gruppe Türe schön
warm ist und dann mit dem Rest
runterkühlen und ich werde trotzdem
jedes Mal wenn ich kurz ihre Schmelze
irgendwie eine Probe machen wie bei der
Julia prowe immer gucken ob es auch
wirklich
alles so funktioniert und Seen im
schönen Glanz bekommt
das heißt jetzt kurz runterkühlen und
dann noch mal ganz kurz erwärmen und das
macht er entweder über dem Wasserbad
kurz oder mit dem Heißluftfön
[Musik]
zeige jetzt mal was passiert wenn die
Kuvertüre nicht gut temperiert bzw wow
kristallisiertes also die seit gut
runter gekühlt die erwärme ich gleich
noch mal ein bisschen und bei der SZ so
ich habe jetzt vom Wasserbad
runtergezogen habe sie noch nicht runter
gekühlt und bei der Probe ist mir macht
ja gleich so eine Probe mit einer
Teigkarte die lege ich mal hier ab
und wenn sie jetzt gut wäre dann würdet
ihr innerhalb von einer Minute ungefähr
warte ich gehe vom Herd weiter weg denn
der hat es auch warm und strahlt Wärme
aus
von der wird dir innerhalb von einer
Minute etwa wenn sie gut ist der Rand
schon anfangen fest zu werden und die
Schokolade schön glänzen und wenn es
nicht gut temperiert ist dann bekommt
dann willst du eigentlich gut fest und
zum anderen bekommst du so einen grauen
Schleier und das wollen wir ja gerade
bei Pralinen nicht
wegen Geld zum runterkühlen
[Musik]
so jetzt guckt mal jetzt sind schon 4
Minuten vergangen und die Schokolade ist
einfach immer noch nicht fest das
bedeutet einfach die ist nicht richtig
aufgelöst die ist nicht richtig
geschmolzen und so wird sie auch
aufhören Pralinen nicht fest und auch
nicht auf eurem Kuchen und glänzen wird
sie erst recht nicht wenn sie dann
irgendwann fest wird also muss man sich
eben die Arbeit machen und die
Schokolade eben richtig bearbeiten und
es machen wir jetzt hier also diese
jetzt schön heruntergekühlt muss gleich
noch mal erwärmt werden aber da sind
noch ein paar Stückchen drin die lösen
sich gerade und die hier wird es kurz
erwärmt wie gesagt entweder kurz noch
mal aufs Wasserbad stellen ganz kurz
oder mit einem Heißluftfön arbeiten
mit Strom am besten
immer schön rühren
und dann prüfe ich jetzt auch hier
trotzdem
ob alles passt und beobachte es einfach
jetzt die nächste Minute
so dann hole ich jetzt gleich schon mal
die Pralinen raus denn jetzt geht's
gleich recht schnell
also wenn die Kuvertüre dann bereit ist
so sieht jetzt die Probe aus perfekt aus
dann könnt ihr jetzt die Pralinen
überziehen das schon ein bisschen
aufwändig muss ich sagen also Hohlkörper
Pralinen sind schon einfacher aber es
funktioniert auch also am besten legt
ihr euch die Schale so ein bisschen
schräg hierher
und am besten verarbeitet ja auch
erstmal nur eine Sorte und schmelzt
nicht gleich beide Varianten sowie ich
denn ich mache mir selber gerade
Zeitdruck
und dann lass dir die Praline hier rein
plumpsen drückt ein bisschen runter ich
habe Zähne Pralinengabel aber ihr könnt
ihr ruhig auch eine normale Gabel nehmen
jetzt wirklich keine da habt dann
bisschen Kuvertüre drüberstreichen
dann auffangen und auf der Oberfläche
direkt so ein bisschen zu dran tatschen
Tops Tops Tops dann fließt nämlich die
überschüssige Kuvertüre ab
und dann hier zwei drei mal abziehen
und
nicht fallen lassen
absetzen und die können dir jetzt gerne
noch dekorieren ich nehme es dafür diese
Jobs in
Gold einfach so ein bisschen auf die
Spitze
und das ist auch Schokolade die einfach
noch schön mit metallic Farbe
Lebensmittelfarbe überzogen ist und es
echt eine schöne Deko die man aber auch
gerne bei ist weil es einfach nur
Schokolade ist und keine harte
Zuckermasse
und ich muss sagen es sind zwar ein paar
Handgriffe mehr aber ist auch schön
meditativ
das sind doppelt getauchte Pralinen
eher
unfreiwillig doppelt gedacht und so ne
[Musik]
dann habe ich jetzt hier die dunkle
Kuvertüre habe ich jetzt auch schon
getestet die ist auch sehr gut und da
das gleiche Prinzip eintauchen sonst
Schokoladen Schleier drüber ziehen und
dann absetzen und hier nehme ich diese
Flakes und die sind so Metallic-Rot
richtig schön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die Pralinen sind jetzt fertig und die
übrige Kuvertüre die könnte jetzt
entweder wenn sie noch perfekt
temperiert ist direkt weiter verarbeiten
und z.b. noch kleine Schokoladenriegel
zubereiten auch als schönes Geschenk
oder ihr könnt sie einfach fest werden
lassen und beim nächsten Mal wieder
einschmelzen und wenn ich Schokolade
übrig habe dann gieße ich sie am
liebsten in Eiswürfelbehälter dann wird
sie schön fest dann kann ich sie auch
portionieren und der luftdicht und nicht
geschützt verpacken und sie einfach beim
nächsten Mal dafür nutzen wenn es nur
ganz wenig ist dann mache ich meist noch
so kleine Schokocrossies draus oder
Rocky roads das geht auch aber so habe
ich dann immer einfach die gute
hochwertige Kuvertüre direkt wieder
verpackt fürs nächste Mal
[Musik]
jetzt in die Pralinen fertig und dürfen
probiert werden ich glaube Tolga hat
richtig Lust auf Pralinen
hast du schonmal Pralinen selber gemacht
und danach mini Cupcakes und danach die
Pralinen übertreib halt
[Gelächter]
das war dann schon viel Kraft Keks Mini
also Pralinen
[Musik]
Gertis zitroniger
passt voll gut zu Tonka
schmeckt so
wie du kaufen kannst
bei einem wie nennt man das ist ein
Patissier
voll schön
die sind auch voll schön aus
übrig gelassen zum Löffeln
wird sich schon gemeldet wenn ja okay
also zwei gute Rezepte richtig richtig
gute Rezepte also probiert die Pralinen
echt gerne mal aus wie gesagt entweder
fehlt ihr die Füllung in den Hohlkörper
hat jetzt ein bisschen einfacher oder
erfüllt die Füllung ist so wie ich in
Silikonförmchen und könnte dann aber
auch spezielle Reformen machen das hat
der Vorteil mit den Silikonförmchen dass
wir immer auf Herz Pralinen machen kann
oder Türmchen oder eben noch andere
Formen dass man eben gerade so da hat da
ist mal so was die Optik angeht bisschen
variabler
mit Nachmachen auf jeden Fall also dann
probiert gern auf die Rezepte findet ihr
auf Sallys minus blog.de oder in meiner
App ich wünsche euch jedenfalls viel
Spaß beim Nachmachen und ich finde es
lohnt sich immer gleich die doppelte
oder dreifache vierfache Menge zu machen
weil man im Prinzip diese Handgriffe die
man hat das geht dann als ein Spieler
von Handwerker mehr macht weil dann hat
man sich einmal die Arbeit gemacht mit
der Füllung und einmal mit dem
temperieren und dann ist eigentlich ist
noch schneller durch mit mehr wie lange
haltbar
Scoot nightclub die halten ja ich glaube
bei uns halten die nicht so
gut
[Musik]